i said what will change their behavior
is that the rest of the world reacts to
them and it diminishes
their standing
president biden getting a little testy
with the press after his big meeting
with vladimir putin
the high stakes summit wrapping up
earlier than anticipated today and as
expected cyber attacks were a big topic
of discussion
putin predictably denied any involvement
in the crippling hacks that hit key
american infrastructure and claimed the
united states is actually the biggest
cyber bully in the world
and president biden responding by saying
he gave putin a list of targets
that are off limits i talked about the
proposition that certain critical
infrastructures should be off
limits to attack period by cyber or any
other means i gave them a list
if i'm not mistaken i don't have it in
front of me 16
specific entities i pointed out to him
we have
significant cyber capability
and he knows it he doesn't know exactly
what it is but it's significant
and if in fact they violate these basic
norms
we will respond there are no threats
just as simple assertions
made and no well if you do that then
we'll do this
with anything i said president biden
taking a lot of criticism for holding
separate news conferences and giving
putin a solo platform where he was able
to attack the united states unchallenged
in moments like this
and in american cities every day people
are killed
that includes the leaders of various
organizations
you can't say a word about you you don't
have time to say a word and somebody's
killed an entire movement developed
known as black lives matter i'm not
going to comment on that
but here's what i do want to say
disorder destruction violations of the
law it's etc
all right now by tomorrow the summit
will be behind us jesse
give us your take on everything here so
the way i saw it
the russians hack us and bind invites
putin to a summit and gives him a list
of things he's not allowed to hack
you got to be kidding me dana and then
there's no consequences there's no deal
there's nothing concrete
he said putin's innocent just some
criminals in russia did it
we'll see if he can stop it calls it a
constructive summit
so then the reporter says um what makes
you think that vladimir putin's actually
going to stop doing this
and joe biden says because vladimir
cares about world opinion
vladimir cares that other people in the
world think about him and he wouldn't
want to hurt his popularity in the rest
of the world i'm thinking of myself
that's actually biden biden cares about
what the russians think about us what
the chinese think about them what the
europeans think
and so he's not america first because he
doesn't want to be the bad guy even if
being the bad guy
is good for america he wants to be loved
more than respective and that's the key
to the biden doctrine
then the reporter says i think it was
ducey did you ask vlad for help about
getting to the bottom of the china virus
and biden says no no i didn't really do
that and again
china is really concerned about world
opinion and their image in the world is
really taking a beating like
china's gonna say oh yeah it came from
the lab just to boost their popularity
he doesn't get it next reporter mr
president
you're saying the hacks came from inside
russia
but vlad is saying no they didn't
actually
hacks come from america so how is this a
constructive
conversation and biden snaps at the
reporter
loses his call wags his finger in her
face and at this point he knows he
screws up
no discipline and he has to go clean it
up on the tarmac before he gets back on
the jet
sure all right uh here is
the tarmac scene right after this press
conference here you go
look to be a good reporter you got to be
negative you got to have a negative view
of life okay it seems to me
the way you all you never ask a positive
question
all presidents get mad because reporters
ask questions and under all like
sunshine and light right
so it didn't go well he knew it didn't
go well so he had to take some more
questions
and ends up basically trying to convince
the press that something came out of the
summit
when nothing came out of the summit and
it looks to me like even the reporters
now know
biden's just about talk for the sake of
talk he's not about
action it was like um i was thinking
greg oh this is an analogy i haven't
thought out all the way through and i
have not asked permission i will give
myself permission now
um like i've never been to marriage
counseling but i imagine that like the
first meeting of marriage counseling
it was between really contentious
partners would be like this
where they afterwards they have to come
out and like have a separate phone call
that they can't like cannot be seen
together yeah well that's not how it
goes
oh how does it go tell us to jesse's
point
the most bizarre part of this whole
thing was when he
said in an effort to sound tough here is
a list
of american entities that are off limits
which makes you suggest
you mean there are there are entities
that are on limits
so what's that list the first one is fox
news yes you guys can hack fox news but
if you go after my dear cnn
we're not talking even you know they i
think they did because seltzer what's
his name seltzer
ratings have dropped 76 percent i think
that i blame that on putin okay here's
the take home
i got sidetracked putin got a pipeline
we got captain cranky pants so great job
shades
not only did putin have the energy he
went home with the energy
biden seemed way more defensive he was
like a teenager yelling i did my
homework
you know to the parents meanwhile putin
is kind of like a relaxed alert
iguana basking on a river rock it felt
just totally out and that
this is it's not entirely joe's
president biden's fault putin is like
how wooderson
describes high school endazed and
confused here's an analogy
i get older they stay the same age
putin has been there being putin for
five presidents
so every semester america's got to
repeat the same class
right but he gets a new guy every four
to eight years
so there's no real incentive for him to
develop a long relationship
that was also same with uh china as well
so they keep
changing he like the girls in high
school just keeps staying the same
peter ducey was able to yell out a
question and it got answered but it was
trying to finally connect what i think
is kind of elephant in the room harold
uh
that russia and china are getting closer
together
and there's financial relationships
there and possible other cooperation
look i i have a a slightly different
take on the uh
on on the the the summit i think it was
two adults who don't like or trust one
another
uh i think it was our president uh
making clear to him i i found a little
odd saying these are off limits and i
think
the second question is what's on limits
but i think he he basically said to him
we know you did it
uh you're going to say you didn't do it
um and when he
how he reacted to that in the meeting i
i don't i don't i don't know but i
thought
again he reset the relationship with
russia laid out very clearly we're two
adults here's what you
what you can expect from me going
forward and what you can expect from the
united states
don't be detractors and just i don't
necessarily agree with all the things
you said but i understand some of the
frustration that some may have with how
this
might have gone and we're looking for
big deliverables the big deliverable for
me was that he went to the g7 and nato
reunited us there and then went to see
putin saying i'm speaking on behalf
of the world here you're not going to
have to reign the free reign you've had
over the last several years
you've gone through five presidents you
may go through two more but i tell you
this
your big challenge putin is that you
want to be relevant and you're no longer
relevant
we're going to organize our national
security strategy over the next 10 years
around how to beat china in a new cold
war your your old news your bad news and
if you do more we will retaliate that's
what i heard
yeah i don't think we're speaking the
same language i don't think putin's had
free reign for the last few years
he just got a pipeline and then he got a
summit and then there was no
consequences for the hack so
i i think uh what you might be talking
about the deliverables are right it's
like
the summit is one thing degan but then
that's the follow-through so what where
do we go from here
right i'm waiting to see how many of
this these 16 targets
get hacked because he basically just
told vladimir
number one number two i didn't quite
like
biden's holier than stan holier than
thou stands on human rights abuses given
the fact that secretary of state tony
blinken
punted bigly when he met with uh people
from the chinese communist party
back in march i mean he got his ass
handed to him
quite frankly so on that front russia is
the jv
team when it comes to human rights
abuses compared to china
so if biden when and if he ever meets xi
jinping
he needs to step up and not let
murderers
tyrant or tyrants tell us uh what's
right and wrong and say hey
uighurs two million people in
concentration camps and go through the
list
i did like there's some decent stage
craft going on with bad today
where he's like oh the sun's getting hot
and he doffs his suit
i got it i was uh excited and folds it
and then he's got
his aviators at the ready it created
that moment of like
oh goody grandpa still knows how to draw
a stick
i have to tell you that but in terms of
like stagecraft the advance work on for
the by the americans compared to the
russians was
much better in terms of the backdrop for
the press conference well done can i
point out that there's going to be
something
when trump ever said anything that was
like directionally true
but maybe false or whatever he'd be fact
checked to hell
no one is going to fact check president
biden so i have to point out that when
joe said
that the people who breached the capital
killed an officer
i was under the impression that that's
not the case and that a police officer
actually killed
an unarmed female protester that wasn't
mentioned
so i think that he was when he said that
the people that breached the capital
killed an officer
i think he was being harder on trump
than he would have been on putin
which is pretty divisive for the grand
unifier but that's not going to be fact
check hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else